[Music] I have to ask how do you take your
coffee I drink my coffee straight in Black
if it's not good enough to drink
black it's not good enough coffee
well it depends on the time of the day I'm
not really super fussy I guess but you know
I'll drink a Milky coffee in the morning but
generally I like straight filled coffee no
milk no sugar oh my gosh how do I take my coffee
I take my coffee over to my neighbor or a friend
gosh I don't even like coffee
it is shocking but that's the
thing you know you don't have to
be a coffee drinker to care about
this issue we're talking about today
of how climate is impacting coffee
I can't get through the day without at least
two strong cups of coffee then I take it with
the tiniest Whisper of milk and it isn't just
me in the U.S alone an estimated 66 of adults
drink coffee every day technically coffee
is a luxury right it provides nothing that
human beings need nutritionally but to many
coffee drinkers it feels essential Global
Coffee Culture is deeply ingrained in our
daily lives from Los Angeles to Osaka and
for millions of coffee Farmers around the world
it is essential providing a crucial source of
income that is increasingly under threat like
so many other crops we grow coffee is seriously
threatened by climate change it's a delicate
plant and all around the world the land on
which it can be grown is shrinking if things
continue as they are the stuff we buy at the
store could become very expensive or very Bland
or even disappear from our lives altogether I'm
Gabrielle Sierra and this is why it matters today
will climate change take coffee off the menu
[Music]
if you're watching us with your first cup
of coffee take note a warming Planet could
make that drink harder to find your morning
cup of joe could become a thing of the past
experts say the main Bean used to make
coffee is drying up coffee drinkers out
there I am feeling your pain on this one no
matter how you like your coffee the coffee
at the moment 50 of the areas that we
currently grow coffee in will be severely
impacted by climate change by 2050 to the point
of becoming probably uneconomic to grow coffee
in so it's a massive challenge for the coffee
industry [Music] coffee Dorian yep the [Music]
diversity of Hertfordshire in the UK and what he
just mentioned is bad news because we consume a
lot of coffee the world drinks about 500 billion
cups of coffee a year and with 80 of coffee grown
by 25 million small farmers that means a lot of
people stand to lose their way of making a living
so in coffee you've got the environmental
challenges both the challenges involved in
climate change but also the challenges of coffee
growing per se and its impact on the environment
you've got the economic challenges particularly
the challenges of a trading market and you've
got what I would call the Social Challenges which
move beyond the economic too sort of you know how
do we want our societies to look how do we want
to help particular societies survive those kinds
of things and how do we help them transition as
well because transitioning into a place of more
profitability is actually a difficult thing to
do and that dilemma is particularly important
in the world's biggest coffee producing Nations
Brazil Vietnam Colombia Indonesia and Ethiopia
125 million people worldwide depend on coffee
for their livelihoods this is Amanda Grassi
she works at the international Research Institute
for climate and Society at Columbia University in
New York city so this could be Farmers Roasters
Sellers and pretty much anyone involved in the
coffee value chain so it's a lot of people and
a surprising number of those people are women
globally women operate about 20 to 30 percent
of coffee farms and represent up to 70 percent
of the labor force in coffee so empowering women
financially has benefits Beyond themselves to also
you know that of their families and especially
their children right so there's this social and
women's empowerment aspect but you know not
only is cocky you know a key source of income
for these millions of people but because of this
it's actually critically important for addressing
issues of food security and many vulnerable
contexts so I'm not saying it's important because
people you know need to eat or drink coffee I'm
saying the use of the income they get from selling
the coffee you know which is a cash crop to buy
food to keep themselves from going hungry to feed
their families and ultimately keep themselves food
secure and nourished is very important and that
this is the case for millions of people around
the world all right before we go any further
let's go back to basics how is coffee farmed can
you quickly outline for me the path from you know
Farm to Table how is coffee made so there are
supposedly 25 stages in that okay I'll try and
simplify a little bit okay yeah so look when we
start by what we call a coffee tree it's really a
bush it's probably about eight to ten meters high
that has a fruit which we call a cherry when the
Cherry turns red we pick that fruit inside the
fruit are the seeds they're what we now call the
beans once we have taken off the fruit dried out
the seeds we take the beans and hold them so we
knock off the kind of the parchment surrounding
them and at that point they are then traded
through various ways through various little men
they get to a shipping point and are then shipped
over to the final country consumer country there
they're roasted and then those coffee beans can
be sold and prepared in the multiple ways that
we prepare coffee for 25 steps that was various
coffee has been a part of daily life for
Generations but in recent years it's emerged as a
massive and lucrative industry serving Discerning
customers who are willing to pay a lot for bougie
Bruce heck Starbucks is a multi-billion dollar
company sure there are some like me who drink
their coffee lukewarm and dazzled but for others
coffee has become a passion the United States
Barista Championship is less than one week away
at this point which is very very exciting welcome
to another episode of coffee Fusion this week
we're going to look at latte art Basics as you're
pouring the milk is coming out of the pitcher
and into the coffee and when it's too high it
sinks but when you back down and as this interest
increases coffee itself faces a crisis clearly
more than ever people love their fine coffee but
no matter how you take it the quality of the end
product starts back at the farm with the first
of those 25 steps and that brings us to the beans
so look there are two types of commercially used
coffee at the moment or it's very much two sort
of dominant ones one is the original coffee plant
that we've always used it's called arabica coffee
ironic because it's actually originally from
Africa but we first came across it in Arabia
arabica coffee is more vulnerable to climate
change it's very sensitive to excessive heat
but it's also as all coffee plants are incapable
of surviving anywhere where there's Frost it's
a little like if you like wine in the sense that
arabica coffee can assume a lot of flavor profiles
from the way that it's grown all these kind
of things very very specific there is another
form of coffee somewhat cheaper somewhat hardier
it's called Robusta coffee commonly it's still
completely sensitive to frost it's slightly
hardier in terms of temperature and it's much
better in disease resistance it doesn't by and
large taste as good tasting notes are not so
clear but the biggest difference between the two
do is that the Robusta coffee has about twice the
caffeine of the arabica coffee whoa so um yeah
if you're drinking a Robusta blend you're getting
significantly more caffeine in there what better
way to understand this than by trying it out
one of our producers Rafaela siewert
gave me a blind taste test so we had
one cup of Arabica one cup of Robusta
and one that's a blend and we wanted to
see if I could really tell the difference
I thought I could put this phone here yeah
yep cool welcome to my world okay so we are here
in our office in New York and I am sitting at the
table with my producer Rafaela hello and I am
about to endure a blind taste test of different
types of coffee that's right I have never done a
coffee tasting I've done wine tasting okay Scotch
tastings I've done yes I've done a whiskey tasting
I'm seeing a theme I'm very excited to administer
I'm excited you're gonna taste each and do a
little guessing and see if you can tell the
differences I think I can tell you think not so
we have them in three identical Council on Foreign
Relations mugs yes so I have no idea which they
are totally black coffee sorry no Whispers of milk
all right so let's start here is your
first cup okay so take a first step
oh wow okay this is like very taste forward
is that something that you say fashion forward
taste forward you know smells good and it's
a little bitter but you know it's coffee okay
stop okay second cup here we go oh funny this
one really doesn't have as much of a smell
First Impressions wow it's much smoother
not bitter this one the first one was
absolutely a bitter coffee interesting yeah
three one okay this one is like a little a
little bitter okay so here's here's
what I think okay blend yes Arabica
you mixed aravica and Robusta what yes no way
yeah yeah joke's on me well this is telling to
the coffee industry that some of us like Robusta
more yeah and it's bad I will say like you can
taste more like it's a stronger flavor in the
Arabica like it tastes like a taste as opposed
to Robusta does remind me of like a more mild
like a comforting sort of dinery coffee right
versus you know something really homey about
a diner yeah yeah and then oh I got the blend
okay you did get the ball I got this so wrong
so what's the takeaway how do you what do we
think about this this is I I'm rethinking all
of my coffee choices well you know what it's in
your best interest because I think that's the
one that's gonna stick around a little longer
in the climate crisis perfect so you're
good the rest of us I don't know thank you
if we could go back just a step could you
break down how the two major elements of
climate change you know temperature and
extreme weather will affect coffee production
basically as we hit higher temperatures the plants
yield goes down yeah so it won't be a kind of an
All or Nothing moment you won't just see coffee
dying but what you'll see is reduced yields and
as the yields reduce at a certain point obviously
it becomes uneconomic to produce the coffee this
is important because coffee crops don't have to
utterly fail in a region in order to disappear
they just have to become so difficult to grow that
farmers give up and move on to another livelihood
as temperatures increase Farms Produce fewer and
lower quality beans pushing them closer to crisis
Brazil is the world's leader in coffee production
and bad weather last year including drought and
Frost has left Farmers there with much less
crop than usual and a number of big coffee
shops large and small have upped their
prices and now those prices are set to
climb even higher the average price for a pound
of coffee today is 6.11 a year ago it was 4.56
extreme climate change in Brazil that have
massively impacted the coffee price recently
is Frost so if there's a frost and it kills off
coffee plants then you have a real problem because
it takes five years to get those plants back
productive so that's five years with no income so
maybe you can do that if you're a big Plantation
and you have a nice Reserve but you can't do that
as a small farmer it's a long time yeah and so
the disaster in Brazil was followed by a drought
disaster so it's about the two worst things that
could happen if there isn't enough rain there's
no flowering if there isn't enough rain there's no
sort of maturing of the coffee Cherry in the right
way without mitigation and adaptation events
like Brazil's crop failure due to both Frost
and drought are going to happen more often more
intensely and in more places all over the world it
will be too hot or too cold there will be too much
water or too little to grow the crops that we are
all used to at the same time extreme weather will
also increase the prevalence of plant disease and
it's not just a particular crop or year but the
existence of certain coffee species all together
this is of particular concern in Ethiopia which is
one of the world's most important coffee regions
what if I told you that Ethiopia is the birthplace
of coffee right the origin of coffee and the
world's main Storehouse of genetic diversity
for arabica coffee and that furthermore this
is under threat due to climatic changes and that
this is going to affect the taste of your coffee
oh no I think some people just had a heart
attack so you know coffee that ripens faster
such as with higher temperatures actually has
less time to develop complex flavor profiles
According to some research Rising temperatures
and decreasing rainfall could actually render
as much as 60 percent of Ethiopia's coffee growing
areas unsuitable for cultivation by the end of the
century wow so from a conservation standpoint
the entire genetic diversity of indigenous or
wild arabica coffee is confined mainly in this
afromontaine rainforest that's located in the
West and East of this Great Rift Valley that's
called in Africa so Ethiopian coffee genetic
materials are really important for these
different flavor profiles that I just talked
about but also in breeding programs producing
these high productivity and disease resistant
coffee varieties around the world so what can
be done well obviously as always we need to
mitigate but we can also adapt and for that there
are three primary options one of those is to move
coffee move it somewhere cooler wetter and in
somewhere like Ethiopia moving up in elevation
Upper Mountain does give you quite a degree of
resilience [Music] Brian Davis Church leader of
Global change at Q Royal Botanic Gardens basically
he's a top scientist studying crops within the
context of climate change but moving coffee comes
at a cost because it's difficult moving people
it's difficult moving crops so they're all sorts
of Social and economic considerations in play
there now the second option is to modify
the farm Farm Solutions are really really
coffee is to have shade grown coffee because when
you have a tree you know it helps to regulate the
temperature of your coffee Farm actually measures
like this are already being implemented building
out a tree canopy over your coffee crop is a
way to keep them shaded naturally throughout
longer and hotter Seasons it's actually called
agroforestry and we're seeing this in effect
in countries like Ethiopia but I mean Beyond
temperatures we're also talking about you know
impacts with rain sometimes too little rain
sometimes too much rain so you know too much
rain you can do things like terracing for coffee
or what we might call you know cuveting changing
the earth works and soil around the coffee plant
to make sure you know when it does rain the plant
is able to harvest that water and trap that water
efficiently for its growth and if it's not raining
enough for example you can do things like hover
crops and mulching and things like this so I'll
say there's a lot of different things that you
can do and a lot of them are really quite simple
but you know they do have a cost tied to them if
you're planting a tree or if you're needing to pay
someone you know even more labor to work on a farm
because it's hotter outside and you're not making
enough money to begin with this seemingly you
know minimal cost ends up actually adding up to
these quite a lot they're having to increase their
labor they're having to increase their material
inputs and things like this but at the end of the
day you know if this extra effort they're putting
in for adaptation is not reflected in price
you're talking about not fully supporting the
profitability of farmers and their sustainability
in the long run right it's not just up to the
farmers to save us all no it's really not it's
really not so these big coffee companies you
know Starbucks Nespresso Etc all these big
coffee companies should be investing money
back into research and you know not only research
church but profits as well back into implementing
climate smart practices and supporting solutions
that are actually actionable to acknowledge that
there is a cost associated with these climate
changes and variability and help us to internalize
those costs so that farmers don't have to do that
but we definitely have the resources and I think
what we need is some more research and a more will
and some more people you know implementing these
actually meaningful Solutions a solution must
include a marriage of private sector investment in
new technology and carry through to governmental
policies that then incentivize and support Farmers
as they experiment and transition all of that
said there is also one last option starting
from scratch kind of the third option is to
change the crop itself so adopt a different
species other than Arabic or Robusta that's
more tolerant of higher temperatures and lower
rainfalls I mean one of the good bits of news for
coffee sustainability is the fact that we've got
another 128 species oh all right and within that
species diversity there are some useful species
that could help us adapt coffee farming at least
to mid-century and perhaps a little bit beyond
the main focus is on those species that were
cultivated at scale maybe 150 years ago almost
made it as crop plants and that might work today
under accelerated climate change and we have like
three or four really good candidates in that
group so how come these didn't stick before
it's not a great analogy but I guess it's a bit
like electric cars invented over 100 years ago
there were several models 100 years ago but
really didn't stick because there was no need
for them why do you need electric car when you've
got plenty of hydrocarbon but electric cars are
coming into the fore now of course and I think
that's the same with coffee and what you see
if you look at the history of coffee is that
Innovation and replacement only really takes a
hold when there's a crisis hmm the main focus of
the work we're doing right now is on liberica the
other is stenophila coffee which is an interesting
species and that it like liberica was grown and
exported at the end of the 19th century beginning
of the 20th century and then disappeared because
Robusta came along but it grows and crops in
a substantially warmer environment up to 6.8
degrees Celsius warmer that's the mean annual
temperature the world might be on fire but those
look at the climate change projection work
and work around a coffee development program
that's in sync with those changes otherwise
it's just kind of wasting your time I think
so there is potential to use this diversity
to adapt coffee farming to climate change
but we need to start on that work as soon
as possible in fact we should have started
30 years ago but we really need to move quickly
because time is certainly running short in the
long term is coffee destined to be a casualty of
climate change and if so can science save coffee
well I think I can science save coffee yes and no
I think one of the key things we need to really
consider is trying to minimize risk for not only
coffee but for many many other crops if we don't
do something about greenhouse gas emissions if
we aren't serious about carbon neutrality then
any of the measures that I've talked about will be
inconsequential and I really believe that if we're
to have some future for humankind let's face it
then we need to tackle climate change at its very
roots of course coffee is just one example Farmers
everywhere are questioning how they will grow
their crops while facing a world with new climate
realities wheat corn soy wine grapes peaches
almonds the list goes on and while it becomes
harder and harder to farm in traditional ways the
world's population grows that means more amounts
to feed all while the world's leading scientists
try to figure out how to adapt The Way We Grow
our food we've said it before but this whole
transition process is sticky and it's complicated
but maybe if people get shook by the idea of
an empty cup of coffee we will be motivated to
make some important changes before it's too late
our associate podcast producer Rafaela is leaving
us for New Adventures so in honor of this she will
be reading us out we will miss her dearly hi
everyone this is raw from the taste test and
I will be reading us out today since this is
actually my last episode with the team which
is so bittersweet because I just love everyone so
much and I'm going to miss them incredibly okay
here it goes for resources used in this episode
and more information visit cfr.org why it matters
and take a look at the show notes if you ever have
a question or any suggestions or just want to say
hello please email us at why it matters at cfr.org
you can subscribe to the show on Apple podcast
Spotify Stitcher or wherever you get your audio
and if you have the time please please please
leave us a review it really does help the show get
noticed and we also just love to read them why it
matters is a production of the Council on Foreign
Relations the show was produced by Asher Ross and
Gabrielle Sierra our sound designer is Marcus
Zacharia and I'm Rafaela siewert this associate
podcast producer our intern this semester was
more may zanki Robert McMahon is our managing
editor and Doug Halsey is our chief digital
officer extra help for this episode was provided
by Alyssa fielding and Claire klobecista our theme
music is composed by Carrie torhusen and we'd also
like to thank Richard Haas Jeff Reinke and our
co-creator Jeremy Sherlock for why it matters this
is Roth signing off see you guys soon they've
got a zillion tons of coffee in Brazil no tea